[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
well happy friday
happy
happy friday
a great show for you today
you know what happens on friday the
second hour we have bonehead of the week
oh
my
goodness was it close
this week i don't know that we've ever
had a bonehead pole
that was that close
i mean these boneheads are pretty pretty
close
to being as boneheaded as the next no
matter what week no matter who it is
that's on the list
these boneheads are always really close
to being
the boneheads of the week but this week
the poll was close your guys's vote was
very very close
but gabe did determine that someone
sneaked it out at the very end
so we'll we'll go over bonehead of the
week in the second hour you know we do
two hours every single weekday right
here on youtube twitter twitch
noon eastern 11 central live
i'm talking you're hearing it
we have another great guest for uh uh
today to give us an update on the war in
ukraine the
occupation of russian troops
of the army of the murderous dictator
vladimir putin who's committing war
crimes
aaron pardnez is going to join us
he's an attorney
he's also a democratic strategist
he's the host the co-host of zoomed in
podcast
on the midas media network
and also he has family in ukraine so
he's been keeping up with
with what's going on ukraine keeping the
news keeping the facts straight
so we want to uh
have aaron on to give everyone an update
uh this is fast moving news you've seen
that the vice president of the united
states kamala harris made clear that
article 5
is iron clad she said
which is something that the former guy
the cheeto dust mobster donald trump
putin's little puppet could never say
not because he didn't want to say it
well maybe he just didn't understand
what article 5 was
he doesn't understand a lot of things
other than how how to unwrap and unbox a
big mac
fed [ __ ]
but the let's go brandon nazis
are very very very very upset
that the vice president is doing and
saying what she's saying so
in that case if the let's go brandon
nazis are pissed off about what she's
doing she must she must be doing
something correct
100
we have a lot of people here this
morning we have lisa robin oh my gosh
everyone's here david's here nolan's
here paddy's here gail's here kevin's
here
debbie salt lake is here
kathy is here
i know i hope mayo is here christina is
here i don't think i'm forgetting
anybody there's a lot of folks here i we
really love having you um every single
day
uh here on the tony michaels podcast
please keep joining us
on the tony michaels podcast on the live
chat
and we will try to work you in as we go
uh everyone's saying uh they love aaron
here yeah aaron aaron gives good insight
i mean not only not only uh does aaron
keep up with the
the facts but he also he also has family
in ukraine so um we'll ask him about
that today
uh everyone saying hey and hi
remember we have some great news here at
the tony michaels podcast speaking of
the chat we have super chat now so if
you want to support the podcast you can
do it in super chat with a super chat or
a super sticker
if you're unaware of what that is go
ahead and ask people in the comments
section
they'll tell you exactly how the super
chat works and give us a thumbs up and
subscribe and all that kind of youtube
stuff you know don't forget to subscribe
to the youtube channel
for all of our videos uh
to give you an announce another
announcement this weekend we're going to
air i'm not sure exactly the exact time
and what channels we'll be airing it on
so keep keep pay attention to the tony
michael's pod uh twitter account my
twitter account and gabe's twitter
account and midas touch twitter account
we're probably going to air the entirety
the extended version
of the interview we had yesterday with
walter masterson a great interview
walter is absolutely hilarious but not
only that the guy was in the trenches
during the entire 2020 election even
with the pandemic going on he went to
tons of rallies he was at the january
six insurrection he was there
there he tells that story in the
interview
we have an extended here we play trivia
also if you didn't catch the show
yesterday but if you did catch the show
and did catch the interview there's like
45 more minutes
of that interview that we want to play
so we're gonna we're gonna post that
sometime this weekend
so keep keep your eye on that but don't
forget to subscribe to all the channels
follow us at tonymichaelspot on twitter
and follow me and gabe at the tony
michaels and i am gabe sanchez gabe's
going to join us in the second hour for
bonehead of the week
he's getting all the the graphics ready
you know gabe does all the graphics here
so he's getting all those ready
for us for bonehead of the week
and then after aaron comes in we will do
a little bit of the
the shitless roundup uh we we like to do
the [ __ ] list here
where we round up all the tweety tweets
and attorney trends so that's what's on
the agenda today
today
the schedule is we're gonna have aaron
parnez give us an update on ukraine
we're gonna do the [ __ ] list roundup
and then we're gonna have bonehead of
the week
for the final hour in the second hour
you know we do two hours a day
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central youtube twitter twitch you can
also go download it
if you love the audio version
you can go download it on all your
directories even the ones that are most
famously boycotted
spotify apple google i heart radio
there's a ton of them out there
go check it out you can go to
thetonymichaels.com
and check out
all the places you can download the the
podcast all the links are there
also visit the merch stores while you're
there if you want some [ __ ] merch um
some people were asking about [ __ ]
hats if they were printed or embroidered
those hats on that store are embroidered
those hats are embroidered and there's
several different choices that you can
choose from on
the [ __ ] merch store also visit
gabe's store there he's got some really
he's got the bobo the clown t-shirt
i don't know if you guys have seen that
you gotta go check out uh go check out
the merch stores at the tony just go to
thetonymichaels.com go to the
the link in my bio and you can find all
those links
right there
right there you can find all those links
uh let's see let's let's let's go to
some um news here
before we have not official treaty
tweets and trinity trends
but i want to um
talk about a bit about some of the news
that's happening in ukraine and russia
before we have aaron on here i think
that's um
worth uh
because we're gonna ask him uh we we
don't have him for a long period of time
uh maybe we'll have aaron on and uh in a
couple weeks and do a longer interview
so we can dive into this a little deeper
but we have them for about 15-20 minutes
today
so i'm hoping uh we can make the rounds
and get some some questions answered uh
thank you lisa for the super chat
the midas mighty midas touch pods thank
you tony and gabe thank you lisa we
always love having you here and i love
chatting with you guys even in the
the other podcast on the midas media
network rather be the minus touch
podcast legal af
i try to make it to those chats if i can
if i if i get a chance to watch those
shows live
and we appreciate you guys watching here
live and listening live on youtube
twitter and twitch
so let's let's um let's see if we can
go to
it looks like there is some uh news
in ukraine uh russian attacks hit cities
across ukraine
as invasion
continues
um
so they are making advancements in some
places they're not making advancements
in others that's one thing that i'd like
to ask aaron about because i think he
knows a little more about you know where
they are making advancements where
they're not
i think that's that's pretty important
of
how successful the russian army is in
some of these places and how
unsuccessful they are in others we seen
the other day they they bombed them
attorney hospital killing women and
children burying women and children
innocent women and children underneath
the rubble
of their destruction
i'm sure that will come up in this in
our talk today
but also we also have trending uh tulsi
gabbard speaking of russia and russian
assets it appears that tulsi gabbard has
taken
uh
campaign donations from a russian agent
oh who would have guessed that so tulsi
gabbard is in the russian news for
crying out loud
you can't make this [ __ ] up
you cannot
make this [ __ ] up of course everyone
knew
everyone knew rush tulsi gabbard is a
russian asset
who didn't know that
because let's face it this isn't like a
democrat republican issue
it's it's just it's just rather you are
compromised or not
tulsi i don't actually believe tulsi is
a democrat i don't think most people in
the pro-democracy party would consider
her pro-democracy she loves
authoritarians
not only does she love authoritarians
she takes money from authoritarians
and we speaking of money and
authoritarians
uh deutsche bank
today announces i'm sure this will come
up too in our conversation with aaron
deutsche bank announces they are not
going to cut ties with russia
no [ __ ] sherlock
how why would they get rid of their
[ __ ] russian laundry mat i said
washing machine factory this morning
washing the machine factory laundromat
we all know what the [ __ ] going on
we all know what's going on if there's a
bank willing to lend donald trump and
his family money we know that it's a
money laundering operation
not hard to [ __ ] spot
this isn't this isn't difficult to
figure out
duh it's kind of like oh telsey
gabbard's might be a russian agent yeah
no [ __ ] sherlock
no [ __ ] breaking news
breaking news deutsche bank wants to
launder money for russians
yeah breaking i always always uh when i
tweet breaking
i treat breaking and i don't actually
mean breaking
i get that's not [ __ ] breaking news
everyone already knew that [ __ ]
they already knew that [ __ ]
it was already a thing
oh let's see what um there was some more
russian news this morning that i wanted
to ask
aaron about as well um other than the
vice president we have the vice
president i want to ask him about um
standing by the article five iron clad
as she called it commitment um tulsi
gabbard again in the news and then uh we
have deutsche bank um but there was
another there was i thought there was
another i thought there was another
russian
thing here now maybe maybe aaron can
shine some light on that when he joins
us here
um
we had the texas supreme court also
trending i'm not sure what what's going
on there and amtrak's trending
um so we'll get to that in the shitless
roundup after we talk to aaron
and then we'll go into the bonehead of
the week
after that
very exciting stuff
very very very exciting show today so
stay tuned
stay tuned uh for the show today do not
go away
also um let's go to i want to show you
the uh
the bonehead of the week
the poll how close it is look at this
thing
this thing was like extremely close
extremely close let's go over there let
me make this bigger
real quick
so i thought we had a tie
we have a tie
find out who receives bone hand of the
week in today's coin toss now gabe may
have done a coin toss i don't know
but he he says he has a winner
he says he has a winner but we had we
had the contestants were donald john
trump madison cawthorne and ron desantis
which all seemed to be russian assets as
well but it was really close and look
and see the percentages oh boy
so we'll get to that we'll get to that
let's go let's go back to
um
i think we have aaron joining us here
me
aaron how are you hey doing well how are
you i'm doing fantastic doing fantastic
just just trying to uh go through the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends here
as you know we do here on the show um i
know i wanted to bring you on to give us
uh
a little update of ukraine to let
everyone know you're an attorney you're
a democratic strategist um you also are
the co-host of zoomed in podcast but
more importantly you have been keeping
track of this ukraine news not only
because it is of interest to you but you
do have family in ukraine is is that
correct yeah that's correct i have an
uncle an aunt and a little nine-year-old
cousin so oh wow sure
um
are they are where where are in this in
the vicinity of ukraine because that
that's what interests me because it
seems like russia is is having success
in some regions but they're not in
others can you kind of explain why
that's important and what that means
about
um the rest of the world like is russia
going to take ukraine are they not can
you kind of give us an idea of how that
works yeah sure so i think what we've
seen is a really and honestly a complete
collapse of the russian military
strategy before this invasion occurred
back two weeks ago now vladimir putin
thought he could take ukraine within
three hours uh united states officials
and intelligence believed that
russia could take ukraine within 72
hours we're now over two weeks in and as
you said russia's really only been able
to take certain outskirts um of ukraine
and only two large larger towns the town
of harassan which is in the south as
well as the town of mariupo which they
haven't officially took yet but they are
laying siege to the town and just today
over it was reported that over 1500
civilians have died in the past two
weeks as a result of the russian siege
now the reason why
russia hasn't been successful there are
really two reasons first ukrainian
resistance has been extremely strong and
and honestly stronger than the russian
military and the russian government
expected uh many thought uh that
president zielinski because of his
background not many people know but
president zielinski literally was on the
ukrainian version of dancing with the
stars just a few years ago he was an
actor he was a comedian he wasn't this
leader type so many thought that he
would easily just roll over and leave
the country or just surrender and he
hasn't done that and ukrainian forces
have really rallied around president
zielinski so they have fought back
significantly that's number one number
two is russian morale is really at an
all-time low now yesterday i was at the
pleasure of joining a white house
briefing where uh the senior national
security uh
member from the national security
council said that russian morale is low
because russians are don't know what
they're fighting for many of these
troops are being sent into war right now
in ukraine to
not just fight um
well they're being sent for reasons that
they don't know um they haven't been
told by their military leadership why
they're invading ukraine they cannot
personally justify the invasion because
in a lot of ways they're fighting their
brothers and sisters right many
ukrainians speak russian many ukrainians
grew up under the former ussr when it
was one country and many russian
soldiers don't understand why they're
fighting this war and so you've seen a
lot of defections you've seen a lot of
russian soldiers surrender to ukraines
to ukrainian forces and you've seen the
russian military just not be able to
gain ground
now with that being said
um
i personally believe based on what i've
been covering what i've seen that if
russia continues its invasion if russia
continues putting forth the forces that
it has and is able to encircle kiev
which is its next plan key of the
capital of ukraine that it will be able
to take ukraine it will be able to
reinstall a russian government in
ukraine
now the ultimate goal of vladimir putin
isn't um necessarily to take land in
ukraine because a russia is already big
enough and b the land in ukraine isn't
super um it isn't strategically
beneficial to russia necessarily but
rather vladimir putin wants to recreate
the former soviet union through these
proxy governments he has one in belarus
with dictator lukashenko already um he
had one in ukraine when president
yanukovych viktor yanukovych back in
2010 was president but yanukovych has
since fled from ukraine and is being is
been in exile in russia and he wants to
reinstall yanukovych reinstall a
pro-russian government a demilitarized
ukraine quote-unquote and um
he will in my opinion will be successful
in doing that but it will just take a
lot longer um and at the end of the day
like president biden has said
um i don't think russia can call this a
win even if it is able to take ukraine
the reason why is because ukrainian
morale is at an all-time high russian
morale is at an all-time low and no
matter what putin does he's not going to
be able to unify the ukrainian people
and that's going to cause them a lot of
headaches moving forward um so although
russia has the military might that um
it theoretically could take over ukraine
if it continued pushing because ukraine
only has so many resources available to
to fight back um
he's already lost this war um in a lot
of ways
so
so that those are some good points that
you make and and a lot of people have
been saying you know oh well if trump
was still president um
vladimir putin wouldn't go in ukraine
and isn't there a case to be made that
the reason why possibly putin wouldn't
go into ukraine if trump was still
president is because he wouldn't have to
because he would have a president united
states who was trying to overthrow the
government essentially and undermine the
government of ukraine like yes why why
wh why why in the hell would vladimir
putin go into a country where the
president of the united states if it
were donald trump was helping him
undermine ukraine like he was the four
years he was um because we see the vice
president which i want to play that clip
here she she says
america stands ironclad behind article
five but we know the former president
probably didn't even know what article 5
really was essentially
no you're 100 right and you hit it right
on the nail and i said this many times
and is that yeah i i do agree with
donald trump if donald trump was
president this invasion would not have
have occurred but for the reasons you
said not because donald trump was tough
on russia for whatever reason but rather
because donald trump during his four
years in office spent those four years
destabilizing ukraine he first um called
out nato and threatened to leave nato
every chance he got by thereby weakening
the nato alliance he then um remember he
was impeached for literally conditioning
um security guarantees and aid to
ukraine on the investigation of
political rivals um and and he spent and
he even spent time supporting the
russian government and supporting the
russian intelligence by in helsinki that
famous moment when he essentially agreed
with vladimir putin agreed with russian
intelligence and completely discounted
american intelligence that russia
meddled in the election um so yeah why
would vladimir putin want to disrupt
that when trump is disrupting it for him
um so i think this invasion was planned
for a very long time not many people
realized but
this invasion has been occurring since
2014 when putin first went into crimea
um and i think putin expected to launch
a further invasion um but he didn't need
to over the past four years trump was
doing it for him trump set the set kind
of the
um
the groundwork for this invasion in a
lot of ways well you know you say it
goes back to crimea but i almost you
know you look back at uh vladimir putin
you know i don't know i think the guy's
mired in delusion now but you go all the
way back to the when they uh invaded
georgia
and even then even then you could almost
make the argument that that even then
this was part of the plan
now whether vladimir putin understood or
had in his little uh in his little ideas
that trump would become president he
definitely wanted to use the candidacy
of trump to cause chaos and then once
trump became president i think that kind
of changed his game plans and as he as
he's watched trump lose and not only
lose he couldn't win the big lie
argument he couldn't win overturning the
election the january six insurrection
that you know they kept of course trump
loses all the time it's just a loss
after loss after loss
this guy's a loser um but as vladimir
putin watched that happen it became more
evident that he was going to have to do
what he wanted to do before trump became
president which was to do an occupation
of a sovereign nation which is ukraine
and and try to try to like you said
install his russian puppets into that
government um because
i think i think and i've been saying it
here is that
really vladimir putin's enemy
is democracy right um and ukraine and
you can speak to this better than i
think most because you do have family
there you do have ties there you do know
about the government there
a little better than most
ukraine is not a perfect democracy
it's a very corrupt democracy but
in a world where if you rewind the clock
back to
before barack obama when george w bush
was president the republican party in
this country
would say things like oh we're trying to
spread democracy around the world
and we we fast forward all the way to
this moment and we have people in the
republican party who are not only
abandoning that idea but almost rooting
against democracy for putin because they
know that authoritarian figures whether
it be putin kim jong-un or their orange
deity donald trump
it it really does democracy is their
enemy it is not their friend and i think
that is ultimately part of
not putin just putin's delusion but his
ultimate task here is to undermine
democracy what's your thoughts no i i
agree 100 and i think that that's what
we've seen um during the trump
presidency and and the reason why
vladimir putin was so in favor of donald
trump's presidency
the russian government didn't care
whether it was donald trump or some
other madman in office in america what
their ultimate goal is is to sow
division in america
and you see you see that all the time
whether trump was president obama was
president bush was president biden's
president doesn't matter and now even to
this day the russian government is
parroting the um idea that uh that
because uh that we're here today because
of the big lie essentially what donald
trump um himself has said and and the
only reason they're doing that is
because they're trying to sow division
in america and they're trying to disrupt
democracies around the globe and and i
think you make an interesting point and
a critical point in that um
our the republican mindset the brain
think of let's spread democracy has
substantially changed and you're right
that ukraine is not a perfect democracy
but also the definition of democracy if
you ask 10 people you're going to get 10
different answers because you don't no
one really knows what democracy is um
but i do think ukraine is a democracy
it's not a perfect democracy it has
a lot of corruption a lot of um issues
with oligarchs there and stuff like that
but ukraine didn't cause this war
ukraine's corruption did not cause this
war what caused this war was russia and
was vladimir putin's intent to invade a
sovereign nation to recreate the former
soviet union and my message to all these
republicans that are pro-russia or are
not necessarily pro-ukraine but
remaining neutral is at what point do
you step up at what point do you say
something because if he's able to take
ukraine in my opinion he will take
moldova next moldova is not a nato
country moldova is a small country close
to ukraine um and after that there's
nothing stops him from going into nato
countries yeah article 5 is a threat and
article 5 in theory
would mean that the united states is
brought into the war but remember the
united states is
thousands of miles away from europe we
are
separated by from russia by a major
tundra in siberia on one side and a
major ocean on the other side we will be
fine um but are you okay with vladimir
putin going into poland
latvia estonia um romania i mean where
does it stop when do you stand up and if
you don't stand up now um unfortunately
you're enabling vladimir putin to go
into these other countries and to
ultimately achieve his goal of gaining
this
power and making russia this preeminent
superpower that it once purported to be
you know i think i think all those are
are excellent points and and i it's it's
the article five issue of course uh
today we see these same republicans that
we're talking about here they're they're
saying
that that vice president kamala harris
is the worst vice president in history
in history because she went and defended
article 5. i have that clip here let me
let me see if i can play that clip and
then we'll we'll talk about it here
i've said many times
including this afternoon with the
president
and the president's leadership
but around the world and i will say it
here
america's
commitment
to article 5 is ironclad
we take very seriously
our role
and the relationships that we have
within the nato alliance
we take seriously
and are prepared to act
on the words we speak when we say
an attack against one
is an attack against all
i believe that that's uh very
significant and a lot of people don't
know what article 5 is but the reason
and this shouldn't be significant right
like the vice president united states
going over and defending article 5
shouldn't actually be significant it
should be just like that should be what
happens right the reason why it's
significant is because the last
administration not only not only scoffed
off article 5 but the president united
states was like [ __ ] nato it's worthless
and he even said he even said the words
what does it have to do with us right
and i think that's to your point that
you just made and the point that the
vice president is making here um so how
important do you think it is not only to
like you're saying to uh nato security
those nations in the eu but our security
to make sure
that article 5 stands it's absolutely
critical uh because when you think about
it yeah ukraine in just ukraine or just
moldova in a vacuum may not impact
united states the united states
substantially from a security
perspective but if vladimir putin moves
further west moves into more european
countries we see a lot of secondary
effects um just by just already i mean
our gas prices are skyrocketing not
because of president biden but because
of vladimir putin's invasion
and that those are only going to go up
inflation is only going to go up the
supply chain is only going to get more
disrupted if he continues this it's
going to turn into a global catastrophe
both economically but also humanitarian
wise where are all these refugees going
to go they're going to go to the united
states a lot of them and are we prepared
to accept all these refugees i would
hope so but not many republicans are um
and uh are on that same
wavelength i mean and and my thing is
it's like
i it's it's absolutely critical that as
a country that we uphold our agreements
with our allies um and one of those
agreements is this art this concept of
article five because
we would hope that if russia were to
launch a direct attack on us that our
allies in europe would also stand up and
say okay an attack on the united states
is an attack on us that includes germany
which has substantial ties to russia the
united kingdom um france and others um
and it do i think that article five here
will be eventually imposed no um i don't
think putin is
i'll caveat this with um i hope he isn't
crazy enough to go and attack nato
country but nothing i mean
i don't see anything stopping him right
now um other than his himself and his
own military and his own and all his own
defects um in the russian morale um so i
mean we'll see what happens i don't
think article 5 will be imposed i hope
it isn't imposed but if is it but if it
is imposed we need american troops on
the ground we need american troops
defending american sovereignty and amer
and our allies because if we don't
defend them eventually it's just going
to be a massive russia a massive china
and us and what are you going to do when
you have no allies right well you know
those those um you know i like i like
the vision of you know what do you want
do you want just three world powers and
that's it or do you want to make sure
that there's
you know competition as it were if
you're
considering a market speaking of markets
and gas prices um you know that that is
that is a lot of the conversation around
um this country right now and they are
blaming on the administration but not
only that the the republicans back to
the the putin republicans
i i believe yesterday mitt romney came
out
and lindsey graham also and they were
trying to excoriate the pro-putin part
of their party which is basically the
entire party not only not only the
politicians but also the talking heads
like tucker carlson fox news oan and
newsmax um basically parroting and also
content creating for russian propaganda
literally content creating for russian
propaganda yeah mike pompeo and the like
but mitt romney i i found it very
laughable that yesterday uh he found one
inroad to uh to bipartisanship with the
migs um i believe that is something that
needs to happen but for mitt romney to
stand up all of a sudden and get in
front of a microphone and be like oh
yeah that's that's the thing we want to
do right i'll i'll stand up for that it
really it really uh i don't know i think
it's kind of like a wet fart and a white
thong it just it's not it's not really
can we take mitt romney seriously can we
take this stuff that they say seriously
like when we're talking about when we're
talking about uh russia and if if their
party is pro-putin can we really take
this stuff seriously i mean we we can
take it seriously from people like mitt
romney from people like liz cheney adam
kinzinger but when you think about it
they are the minority in the republican
party these days the majority of the
republican these days are the pro putin
the um america first uh republicans so
yes we can take what they say seriously
but
you need more than one senator in the
senate you need more than two members in
in the house so um yeah you could only
take it so seriously to an extent so i
so i want to push back a little bit on
the mitt romney adam kindergarten and
liz cheney and i i want to challenge you
a bit and the reason why is because i
believe that the what happened yesterday
with lindsey graham and mitt romney is
they see they see a little bit of a
hallway to get their party back does
that make sense so they've kind of lost
their party to the like you said the
america first let's go brandon nazis and
really because because they have this
hallway this little glimmer of light at
the end of this tunnel like oh maybe we
can maybe we can destroy trumpism
and get our party back to be anti-putin
right if we're anti-because that's a
really popular idea and it's going to
become more and more popular as he
becomes
as he commits more war crimes um do you
i i think i think my personal opinion is
is that's them trying to capture back
the old gop and get away from the gqp
and the q anon america first type thing
i don't think it's as genuine as people
want to believe and maybe i'm wrong i
mean listen it definitely could be um
and if this is what they want to use to
get back to the old guard of the gop i'm
all for it in my opinion um because at
the end of the day i want to defeat
trumpism and i'd rather have you have
two rational parties that can work
together that can negotiate with one
another and that can achieve real
solutions i would love to get to that
place we're not at that place we're not
anywhere close to that place but if this
is one step closer to that place i'll
take them for their word here and then
attack them on other issues because at
the end of the day something that i've
um
really preached when it comes to this
war and on my tick tock and elsewhere is
that war cannot be partisan we this is
one thing that has to unite us as
republicans as democrats and as
independents and unfortunately several
republicans have chosen a completely
different route but if there are
republicans out there that want to come
together with the administration and
with democrats and stand strong against
putin and russian aggression i'm all
forward because we need a strong face
because at the end of the day what does
vladimir putin want he wants a divided
america so if we can show a united
america at least in this context we're
already hitting him where it hurts the
most
so a more good points by you and i
appreciate uh uh going head-to-head here
on that issue but i i will i will say
it's not just republicans because what
we've seen um is tulsi gabbard is in the
news this morning she's a republican
well right but you know
dino i guess you call it debt democrat
in nineteen
you know they always want to throw her
in the rhino maybe we we we do the the
dino um but uh
we also had two two democrats uh vote
against something the other day um which
was kind of disappointing
so it's not just republicans it also as
democrats not that not that democrats
shouldn't have the right to vote against
or be russian assets i guess i don't
know uh
we'll find out and one thing i do want
to ask you before we leave because i i
believe that these war crimes and i know
you've been following it very closely um
that's one thing i want to ask before
you leave if i can if you've got a few
minutes for sure is
we saw the other day that uh the russian
army uh
bombed
a maternity hospital
and they've been committing what seems
like other war crimes do you believe
that uh this
the these these events are turning
points uh in this conflict to where um
more of the world uh because we did see
china uh give some pushback to russia
and we've seen some other pushback now
of course deutsche bank did not um
because they're you know uh they have
that uh money line i mean excuse me that
money relationship with russia but d do
you see that as putin's delusion makes
him and his army commit more and more
war crimes
what what do you think the effect is on
that well i mean i think that russia is
already a pariah on the world stage i
don't think there's anything putin can
do to make it more so than it already
has been i mean unless he uses a
chemical or nuclear weapons obviously i
think that do you think maybe that's his
that's his goal here is because he's
just trying to push the limit and he
knows these are war crimes do you think
that might be part of it well i i mean i
think that i i definitely could see him
using chemical weapons i don't see him
going nuclear but as far as him thinking
their war crimes when you think about
that concept of war crimes you don't
have an international police that are
going to go in and arrest vladimir putin
he doesn't have any actual
accountability his country is already
facing the tightest sanctions it can
countries like china saudi arabia india
and others are going to remain either
neutral or on russia's side and remain
economically involved because it
benefits them um because china is not
going to ever be 100 in ukraine's corner
right because it won't that doesn't
benefit them and when you think about it
you have um
all these complaints in the
international court of justice and the
international criminal court but
nothing's ever going to come from that
why because first the international
court criminal court russia is not even
a party to the rome treaty that the rome
statue that created it so russia's not
even under its jurisdiction so throw
that aside and then the international
court of justice
all it's going to do is issue a
statement or a
report outlining russia's war crimes and
then that's it and and then maybe a
captured general in ukraine may be
helped that may be tried in the hague
but the chances that ever happens are
less than one percent so there really is
no accountability here for vladimir
putin he does want to push the limits
and he does have support in it i mean he
does have belarus's support he does have
other conflict for example i'm not
saying mexico supports this mexico of
course doesn't support this but mexico
has remained neutral india has remained
neutral china in a lot of ways has
remained neutral saudi arabia has
continued that oil relationship with
russia so um until every country around
the world including countries like north
korea venezuela and belarus stand up to
russia russia is always going to have
kind of skin in the game with other
countries and um
i i don't know what i i don't know if
this is the turning point i don't think
this is the turning point i actually
think the true war hasn't really even
begun yet right i think we're going to
see an increased amount of escalation in
the next several days as they try to
take here um but i think i think the
turning point will be either they a them
taking kiev or b
um them using chemical weapons and
hopefully neither happen but it's
looking likely that either either one
will occur
that that's uh that's disappointing to
hear but i i i think that you being up
on the facts and we do appreciate you
coming on you're welcome back anytime
tell us where where tell us where
everyone can find you because i know you
do a lot of tick tocks to keep people up
on this and you're constantly tweeting
uh news out so tell us where tell
everyone where they can find you um that
way if they want to follow you and
follow the news yeah for sure so at erin
partners i think my ads up here or other
side yep there we go right there right
there right there uh at aaron partners
is my twitter and my instagram and then
just throw the number six at the end
aaronpoint6 and that's my tick tock i
post every hour there um updates and
clips so make sure to go check it out
uh thank you for joining us aaron
everyone go go follow aaron on all the
socials
and keep up with him he's on the
instagram the tick tock the tiki talks
and the tweety tweets thank you so much
yeah hey thanks for joining us aaron
everyone stick around we'll be right
back
uh after these messages with the [ __ ]
list roundup thank you aaron we'll see
you soon thank you bye-bye
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
and it means you'll get these trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we want to thank aaron harness again for
joining us giving us some updates what
his thoughts are in ukraine not just
not just what's happening on the ground
but also what's happening uh politically
around the world and in our country and
how it uh affects us politically
whether you're republican or you're a
democrat
um speaking of republicans and democrats
in the news for russia i still have
aaron's thing up there i'm going to take
that off
see
see
there we go there we go
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
i'm still trying to get used to the
whole production thing you know it's
just me over here running these things
there's not some kind of crazy person
behind the board and behind in a
different room it is me just me and then
when we have gabe on you know gabe's
helping do things too speaking of that
stick around for the second hour here
soon we will have bone hint of the week
we're gonna have bonehead of the week
um here in just a bit
uh
and we'll look at see who won the coin
toss i think it was a narrow win
it was a narrow win i believe so we'll
do that but first we want to go through
through the [ __ ] list roundup the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends
so you know what let's go ahead and
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome to the shitless roundup
where we ran up all the tweety tweets
and the journey trends of the day let's
go to the timeline
let's make this a little bigger sir
y'all's folks out there can seize
uh we have a lot of stuff uh going on in
the news today uh we have deutsche bank
in the trendy trends let's see what else
do we have um going on in the trendy
trends today we had uh
we have kellyanne conway
uh she likes she would like she would
like for president biden to stick to the
facts apparently well look at that tulsi
gabbard is a russian agent is also in
the trinity trends uh
amtrak i don't i'm not sure why amtrak
the texas supreme court will figure that
out uh hashtag party a treason
you don't even need me to explain that
hashtag like at this point everyone in
the country knows
what hashtag party of treason is
you don't even need to [ __ ] explain
it of course you know what it is
facebook and instagram is also trending
i don't know why i have no idea we'll
find out as we go through the tweety
tweets and the training trends well
let's go down the timeline a bit
there was a lot of stuff going on uh
this morning
we have scott mcfarlane
uh tweeting new
attorneys for rep marjorie taylor green
and thomas messi filed notice of appeal
they're going to continue legal
challenge against nancy pelosi
and the fines levied for violations of
the u.s house mass mandate
the mandate was lifted last month so
there there is no there is no mandate of
course
um these people are trying to fight
mandates that don't exist anymore uh
rather you're marjorie taylor green and
thomas massey on the house floor or
or you're in the dc trucker convoy uh
with the cancun cruise uh mayo says good
morning to everyone who thinks madison
cawthorne is a putin loving trader
yeah he calls zielinski a thug
a nazi thug called zelinski a thug
i wonder if that's a little bit of uh
projection uh joe says here i prefer
presidents who
don't have a thing for despots yeah that
would be nice
be nice to keep a president
of the united states and we really i
mean
in our modern history there's only been
one that loves dictators and loves
tyrants
loves authoritarians because he's
anti-democracy trump said he wanted he
wanted his people
to treat him like kim jong-un's
people treat you know they want he went
he wants them to be scared that he'll
kill them
and
we'll have more news on stephanie
grisham here later but
she said that trump wants to kill the
press which you know is the thing that
happens in russia and north korea [ __ ]
tai says i'd pay good money for someone
to poke holes in stephen miller's coffin
it's not right
oh as you guys know stephen miller
is still on his parents cell phone plan
and i would imagine i would imagine that
the parental controls are still turned
on in his app store
that little [ __ ] [ __ ] oh man let's
see what else we got here
oh here here's a good clip of jordy on
the minus touch podcast last night
uh they had a uh ukrainian diplomat on
and he really punches it uh tucker
carlson so let's take a look at this in
the united states we we actually we have
a network called fox news news and
parentheses here so they've been
broadcasting russian talking points lies
and disinformation what would you say to
them and the companies that allow them
to broadcast their messages i've got
shame on you shame on you shame on you
tucker carlson i mean when you say
why should we
support ukraine and not russia
just what's wrong with your moral
compass what's wrong with your soul i
mean how dead is your soul
when you when you say like say things
like that when when ukrainian pregnant
women
get bombarded when ukrainian children
are rescued from this rubble that used
to be their homes i mean you ask why
ukraine should be supported i mean
there is something seriously wrong with
this guy and there is something really
seriously wrong with fox fox news if
they give him the air
uh you can watch that full interview
uh on midas touch
youtube channel
or if you want to listen to the
interview you can download those
podcasts wherever they're available
a very very very insightful
view from ukraine into the propaganda
the content creation that is
being made here in our country
for content
for rt
for rt speaking of um
uh madison madison cawthorne is a thug
tree
you guys remember the video right you
remember the video of madison cawthorne
he was uh punching the bark off a off a
dead tree
yeah
uh gabe brings reference to it here gabe
says the tree thinks madison cothorn
is a thug i i tend to agree with the
tree i contin i i actually
agree with the tree um here is uh
lindsey graham
we were talking about this earlier joe
says you cannot stand with donald trump
and ukraine at the same time
it is not possible here
uh let's listen i'll i'll give you some
commentary
on what lindsey graham has to say about
and now he's talking uh about madison
gawthorne and all these putin's puppets
as he is a putin puppet with uh tom
cotton standing behind him one of the
biggest putin puppets let's listen
there's a poll coming out tonight i'm
aware of where putin's approval rating
is 0.7 percent
now i don't know who these people are
but they're not a lot of them
i think the average republican and
democrat in this country would give high
marks to zilinski
do a poll i've seen these polls what
putin has done is done something we
can't do among ourselves
like 90 of the country is with the
ukrainians and as opposed to putin so
when you see a member why is he looking
around
why why the [ __ ] is he twitching and
looking around at these other people is
he trying to spot the ten percent
like all the people standing behind him
are the ten percent
the [ __ ] is he looking around for look
at this guy he look keeps looking around
looking at these
up maybe there's maybe there's a russian
asset oh
no maybe there yeah there may that maybe
there's a russian asset
the [ __ ] out of here so when you see a
member of congress say things like this
the one thing i want you to know they're
outliers
in the largest sense possible
no they're not dumb [ __ ] they are your
party
just just because
just because it isn't convenient for you
to stand in front of a microphone and
support a murderous dictator who's
committing war crimes doesn't mean it's
not convenient for them
they want authoritarianism they want
totalitarianism and you [ __ ] have given
the them the opportunity by can taking
control of your party
you [ __ ] idiot so by you standing by
and putting on your cheeto dust knee
pads and letting that [ __ ] that despot
take over your party as joe says
that wannabe dictator the tyrant that is
trump
you are complicit in what madison corn
and any of the other traitors in your
party would say
on our side and there's some on the left
that are outliers
so let's say
there's one there's one russian agent on
the left and she's not even a leftist
let's let's be frank tulsi gabbard
like aaron said is not a [ __ ]
democrat
democrats in this country
are the only pro-democracy party and
really honestly the democrats should say
you're either pro-democracy or you're
not a democrat that's what the democrats
say you are not welcome in our party if
you are not pro-democracy
we should not welcome anyone who is
anti-democracy into the democratic party
i don't care if they're former
republicans if they're never trumpers if
they're independents if they're
moderates
if they're liberals if they're socialist
whatever they are if you're not
pro-democracy you're not welcome that's
what it should be
this thought that america believes
that zelinski and the ukrainians are the
good guys
and putin's the bad guys and we'd like
to be helping the good guys more
yeah you would you would like to appear
to be the good guys is what you mean
you [ __ ] turd
lady g would vote
to elect donald trump and putin 2024 if
trump and putin could be on a ticket in
2024 lady g lindsey graham
would vote for them [ __ ] this guy
okay let's move on let's see what else
we got here
uh oh
this is a good question you should be
posing to everyone you see
rachel bitkoffer says whatever
republicans done for
rule america
not two
four what have they done
for rural america i think it's a valid
question and that is a question that
should be out front if you're out there
talking to people and rule
america
okay
um you know we had the people's convoy
the other day um
i said something for the people's convoy
claiming to be freedom fighters
let's listen to what george carlin has
to say about freedom fighters
well if crime fighters fight crime and
firefighters fight fire what do freedom
fighters fight
yeah that's that's it if crime fighters
fight crime
and firefighter fight fire
what do freedom fighters fight
very good question okay
let's go to the tweety tweets and trendy
trends we're gonna be go going to bone
head of the week
here in about five or ten minutes as
gabe joins us
oh
i want to get to
a couple of trendy trends here
uh we have
tulsi gabbard
um the official story from the daily
beast here
is exclusive russian american national
elena branson was indicted this week for
lobbering lobbying excuse me for pro
kremlin policies
while not being registered as a foreign
agent this sounds familiar
this sounds familiar
there's been a lot of people lobbying
that weren't foreign agents
she gave to one u.s politician
tulsi
gabbard hmm
i wonder if we can figure out what
tulsi gabbard's pro-kremlin
views came from i wonder
i wonder why
tulsi gabbard would
be pro-putin
and pro-kremlin
i wonder if it has anything to do with
following the money
tulsi gabbard is a russian asset has
been for a long time folks it's not
something new it's not breaking
you just hear what she says uh mueller
she wrote writes breaking the russian
spy charged with espionage light
this week in the southern district of
new york donated to only one politic
political candidate only one
not several just one
it wasn't much but why do russian spies
like tulsi hm
good insight
mueller she wrote
i'd like to get allison on the show
over here i like allison over mueller
she wrote oh
so allison if you're out there if you're
listening hit me up i'll let's bring you
on the show
okay
what else do we have um let's go back to
the trendy trends i i'm not going to
spend much time on tulsi
because i think i think we're going to
go through tulsi again and and uh the
bonehead i'm sure she makes an
appearance there uh we do have the
dishonorable mention and the alpha cuck
of the week so
it's possible she makes an appearance
there uh kellyanne conway is in the news
um she's in the training trends in the
tweety tweets um
she was on fox news's ingraham angle
yesterday last night
viewers react to former presidential
advisor
trump advisor not presidential advisor
there was nothing presidential about her
or trump
former trump adviser kellyanne conway's
remarks on the biden administration made
during first segment of fox news let's
see if we can find this schlub
you know i don't like that i don't like
to hide things here
you don't like to uh you got you can't
look away can't look away christina
thank you for the super chat
i think you got a super chat thank you
very much
christina you guys want to give to the
super chat
it's available now on the youtube chat
we appreciate any of the contributions
you make to the show it helps us
keep going
that way we can bring you
the latest breaking news and the clown
these [ __ ] like we do on the
bone end of the week so let's listen to
this bonehead
talk about how
biden isn't adhering to alternative
facts in crisis and joe biden that he
has this way ginsaki of playing the
blame and gain name and shame
nonsense of washington but it would rely
on the american people believing it and
they've lost credibility not just in
their message and their messengers you
know laura i like to say the democrats
don't have this administration doesn't
have
a messaging problem they have a fact
problem oh [ __ ] miss alternative facts
here thinks that uh the biden
administration has a fact problem
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] get out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
really
what is this
here is uh joe posting here a video
of kellyanne let's see what contains but
during that time why did the
administration send out more tests and
work to get hospitals prepared today the
state of florida is saying they can't
test everyone for the administration's
guidelines
so you're asking a couple different
things there i'll i'll try to just give
some facts uh the hhs secretary said
this morning that we're ramping up we're
ramping up with commercial labs why
didn't they do it while it was contained
get ahead of them it is being contained
and do you not think it's being
contained in this country
facts facts right uh joe says march 2020
kellyanne conway is a serial liar for
whom facts are whatever she wants them
to be history regard her as nothing more
than a
talentless
tupulous deceitful double speaking hack
her 15 minutes are up sign the slitter
back
to the oil slick
which
spawned her
oh
joe so after my heart were their tweets
thank you very much for your your reply
there joe okay
let's go back to the uh
the tweety tweets and trinidrons
kellyanne uh let's see what else what
else do we have here in kellyanne's
do we have anyone else come on and we
gotta have some good kellyanne jokes
we gotta have some good kill we gotta we
got we have we have to clown these we
have to clown these fools it is the
thing we have to do it is our duty to
clown these people
[Music]
oh here's scary larry this has got to be
going
larry's always good kellyanne conway
saying the mind administration has a
fact problem quote unquote is absolutely
hilarious considering she's one of the
most heinous liars of all time
and of course she has the alternative
facts a gif
she is
it's it's incredible it the projection
the [ __ ] projection is always spot on
with these people like they can't
[ __ ] help it
they can't
[ __ ]
help it
but to tell on themselves
and because that's what she's doing here
let's see let's go back to the trendy
trends and the tweety tweets now we have
a few more things trending texas supreme
court is trending
uh
josh has here new texas supreme court
slams the door on federal court lawsuits
seeking to block texas's privately
enforced abortion ban scotus left
this option open last december
but it now looks ineffective
um
it looks like it looks like that the
texas supreme court
has stopped the federal lawsuit is that
what's going on here i'm not sure
exactly
and i want to make sure i get this news
right
we want to make sure we get this news
right here
yeah it looks like that's it uh supreme
court rules against uh abortion
providers changing a fetal heartbeat law
um
do
report here
but it looks like um aj has this here
breaking texas supreme court effectively
blocked abortion providers from
challenging the new anti-abortion law
the law lets private citizens sue people
who aid and abet abortion
but does not let state agencies enforce
it
providers hope to sue state agencies
to overturn it so it looks like they've
stopped
their right to do that the texas supreme
court is doing everything they can to
take liberty away
from people with uteruses if you have a
uterus and you're in texas you do not
own liberty
liberty is not a thing that you get to
have if you live in texas and you got a
uterus [ __ ] you is what republicans say
in texas
you don't get to have liberty that's not
a thing you get to have oh you want body
body autonomy i don't think so if you
live in texas and you have a uterus you
can take your liberty and you can go
[ __ ] yourself that's what texas is
saying
these [ __ ]
all right let's let's go to a break when
we come back when we come back we will
have bonehead of the week
stay right here don't go anywhere
bonehead of the week when we come back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopers mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we have bonehead of the week ready for
you
i believe that uh gabe is with us
bonehead of the week uh
of the week he's very excited about
bonehead of the week here yeah
and uh what's what's going on with
bonehead of the week that you're so
excited just boneheads man bonuses so
many boneheads there's no you know it
was a really close race this week
this week was the closest we've ever had
was like it was i was watching this uh
this poll
at like one in the morning
and
um
right it was like point
it was less than point one percent i
thought we had a tie this morning i
really did we did not walk it was really
close it is so to the to the naked eye
you would say that's a tie hey that
rhymed
but
by its own based on the calculations
from
uh twitter
we do have a clear winner though it's
like one of those it's one of those
shots at the end of the race where it's
like uh like they catch it right and
it's just like somebody right
like so it's like your head a little bit
the tip tip of
exactly the tip of their despicable nose
okay well let's let's start the sound
let's start the intro and then we'll get
to bone end of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
we always love the music here and i
don't know what it is about that yeah
it's also it's you know keeps you going
yeah you know it's a little it's it's
it's high
high note you know it's like a little
like so you know gets the day going and
get a little i think so i think a little
thing in your step you know i don't have
coffee to like get me going oh yeah i've
just got this song yeah this the song in
your little streamy streamy exactly yeah
you know i'm streaming water streaming
the show you know it gets me going into
the weekend where i'm like yeah let's go
oh my god
oh my god so so speaking of uh parties
um you know usually it's only one party
that ends up on the bone of the week but
we do have a surprise
um
this week i think of uh uh maybe a
democrat that ended up on bonehead of
the week yeah it was a very it was a
last-minute addition last minute
decision that's how that's how we roll
with bonehead man that's how it goes you
know sometimes you gotta you know roll
with the punches as it were so but uh
let's let's pull this up here here's the
here's the poll that we had we had of
course donald john trump we had a
representative madison catherine the
tree killer as he was um you're right
you know some people i'd i i've heard
him called this
hitler i don't call him that but oh yeah
i heard that as well yeah but you know
um you know the tree killer it works too
and then we have that that uh that
[ __ ] homophobe down in florida
governor ron desantis yep and we'll talk
about all these we see this is very
close here right like the yeah the
internet i mean it's like neck and neck
look at that see
the naked eye it looks like it look you
know to any non-uh
you know mathematician poll
watcher you know you might say that is
in fact a tie but you know what like any
election you know it might go into the
final you know the hours of the night
and you find out who you are because
there wasn't a clear winner last night i
can tell you that it was so close and
then it was in the last minute that uh
that there was a connie running
so let me ask you because i i the most
surprising thing about this poll
is not that
donald trump and ron desantis the two
men from florida the two florida men
yeah are like neck and neck here i'm
very surprised that madison gothard
pulled as much of this vote as he did
right like like in this poll you would
expect madison gothard to take a way way
back seat in third right nope people
hate that [ __ ] but you know what
just like his illegal driving he was in
the driver's seat and he was going
forward you know right right well and
and maybe that maybe it was the whole
um you know the thug comment thing that
really put him over because he was in
the he was in the news twice this week
so tell everyone why he was in the news
because he was in twice right so the
first time he got in the news was
because uh he was driving for a second
time under a suspended license which
that that to anyone else if they were
caught in this country you know
especially a non-white person you might
find yourself uh
in a in a bit of trouble and also the
way that you're treated right so let's
just let's just call that out for what
it is the second thing he got in trouble
for was he was talking about how
zielinski is the thug and how he's using
propaganda and woke and this and that
and basically you know simping for putin
to say that zielinski's actually the the
villain here he's actually the bad guy
he's the one
that
uh that brought this on himself because
the way that he is right
so those are the in a quick like tl dr
those are the reasons how he got within
one week not even less than that like
within like a three or four day period
he found himself uh in the news and i
actually i actually think the driver's
license thing is you know i think it's
kind of insignificant when it comes to
madison cawthron any other like
representative that was you know
an actual representative who did things
that a congress person actually does
that probably may matter but he's such a
shitty individual like that is so low on
the list of the show yeah he's ever done
yeah right there's so much like as a
like you know he has uh
he i'm assuming he has a driver and and
protection so it's like wouldn't they
just be the people that are driving like
driving around like you know also to
avoid situations like this and to avoid
getting in trouble and to have like some
sort of controversy they'll be like oh
you know i have a driver that takes me
from point a to point b right
so it's just like i don't it just seems
also unnecessary for him to be like
you know driving a car he also has a
terrible record driving cars
uh you know the whole accident that
happened
and his friend
you know switching seats and
doing very dangerous stuff and how that
accident happened well and then the
aftermath and the story of that accident
and the lies that madison gotham tells
about it is kind of disgusting speaking
speaking of what he says and being
disgusting here is the other reason um
why he was uh on the bonehead of the
week uh he and i think i'm not sure
exactly where this is at i was unsure um
it appears to be a cell phone video of
him at some kind of you know
nazi rally or nazi gathering or
something but um let's play what he says
about president zielinski the president
of
ukraine so they can defend themselves
better but remember that zielinski is a
thug remember the ukrainian government
is incredibly corrupt and it is
incredibly evil and it has been pushing
local ideologies and it really does the
new world
okay so he calls president zielinski a
thug
which is um
at this point you know it's not
surprising really that that someone so
in bed with trump and putin and who who
apparently talks to trump every day on
the phone three or four times a day he's
like a father to him right right right
don jr is crying in the corner right
exactly but we have we have here this
this uh
he's a
bonehead he's a [ __ ] bonehead but we
have him not only calling president
zielinski a thug
he says that because the democracy in
ukraine is corrupt and this is this is
the [ __ ] thing i've been saying for
months and months and months
if anything is bad then the alternative
has to be good right right but this is
their perpetuation to say that if if
there's any corruption inside a
democracy
it needs to be destroyed it needs to be
destroyed and then
the thing that i don't understand and i
don't know
why he tied this in is the woke ideology
stuff sky baby woke sky you know
[ __ ] does that it's just it you know
it's
i i feel like the reason that they go
after this stuff is because it's an easy
target right it doesn't mean anything
but it's an easy target to to to like
trigger people to get angry and
frustrated and outrageous just just
because they can say the word woke is
that what you're saying right because
i'll just i'll just throw these these
these buzzwords because woke is the
opposite is like oh you have to be
politically correct oh it's not just
politically correct you have to be woke
about it you know which is funny
considering from a group of people who
say oh you got to wake up take the red
pill and it's like well if you're awake
then you are woke so right
right it's weird yeah so when they when
they say like oh they're woke right
they're like oh those blue-haired
liberals those you know feminazis and
that they say all these things they're
just like a bunch of it's a bunch of
like
uh buzz words that mean nothing but
they've been associated with a group of
people to say if i say this you know
exactly who i'm talking about right like
those people is what he's referring to
in terms of like a group so it would be
the liberals the leftists the the
socialists they want to take over this
country they're woke so zielinski
is a woke leader who's a socialist and
he's a communist and he wants to take
over
the you know europe and the only thing
the only thing that's stopping
but the problem is is the whole [ __ ]
line in russia the whole lion rushes
that they're nazis and they're not woke
they're nazis and that there's this
biolab thing which is another [ __ ]
crazy ass [ __ ] thing that that fox news
it makes no sense considering the fact
that like how many jewish people are
actually residents of ukraine or
zolinski is jewish
exactly so the whole like oh there's
nazis in the military it's like uh i
don't i mean like who knows maybe but
maybe
also the accusation that he is is insane
but maybe there's something to that
maybe the white ideology thing is is the
new cabal right like that's the oh
yeah the new trope the new anti-semitic
trope is right right you know you're the
you're the woke ideology you're the
you're the cabal isn't it oh yeah i i
for 100 totally see that as another way
to associate because somebody will
there's like two points and somebody
will build a bridge if not that like if
not they have already to make that
connection to say oh these woke people
are coming for your guns they're they're
gonna kill these babies they're gonna
eat those babies they're going to drink
their blood they're going to live
forever yeah we got to stop this cabal
of woke leftists uh you know that's
they're just as
words they're just like up pre-pending
and appending words to just like cabal
woke you know and it's and and and i
guess it's not humorous but you got to
see the humor in it because you
they're all in the time that they're
supporting the murderous dictator who's
bombing maternity hospitals right yeah
like it just you can't say they're
killing innocent women and children
right they're supporting that person who
is who is killing innocent women and
children while they're blaming the i
awoke ideology well you also have the
people that are saying things like did
they really bomb those hospitals and
attorney awards you know and you're like
we're gonna we're gonna play that game
right
well i mean i speak speaking of people
uh
uh who who appease to putin um and and
get weird ass [ __ ] like when they when
someone asked him a question now that's
the reason why donald trump appeared on
the bonehead of the week
he appeared on some kind of weird
podcast ufc podcast where he talked
about uh windmills right well other
random [ __ ] well it it's really it
really is a [ __ ] weird clip um
because i forget what the podcast name
is and i don't really even want to say
it here [ __ ] yeah but it really is um
let me see if i can pull it up um
it really is a weird little clip and the
reason why is because
he's asked a legitimate question like i
thought the question you know as stupid
as the podcast may be
i i thought the question i was like oh
okay well maybe maybe he'll give
an answer i you know i don't know i
don't i i wasn't sure if he would or not
right but um here's the clip let me pull
this up here here it is so there and
there's got four million views on this
video number one
when i first seen this because i just
seen like the thumbnail i didn't see the
video playing and i seen him sitting in
this setting it looks like he's in court
oh my god oh my god did i miss the news
i know i thought the same thing i saw
that and i was like who where is this
set up you know where is this
like who released this how did no one
talk about this and then you're like oh
it's a podcast right right it's it's
very the setting the the frame as it
were yeah is really i can't wait to see
a frame like this where he's being held
accountable you know what at this point
i would ask someone online if they just
want to like sketch this out like a
courtroom just call it a day
and just put it out there and be like
here is the prediction i have of what
it'll look like uh you're going to piss
off daniel dale again you're going to
piss him off again and let's
play the clip here it would have never
happened and we did talk about it i mean
he definitely
wanted ukraine loved ukraine would never
have happened okay so he's talking about
putin here obviously um he's talking
about putin's not going to take you
green it definitely he's trying to be
tough guy right and we've seen someone
else who's going to appear in bonehead
of the week this week say that he
actually when he was with putin he would
tell putin hey i'm gonna act tough in
front of the camera so they think i'm
tough on you but i'm not really i'm not
really doing that that's just an act
that's the thing i'm doing yeah right um
and that's what he's doing here and he's
he's already let putin know this years
ago so putin knows that's the game so
but but listen to what happens when this
guy asks him
what seems to be a legitimate question
because it's not a bad question it's not
the greatest form but it is not a bad
question what do you see happening next
then because it seems like the tensions
are high what how does this all end is
this going to be like a long-term thing
how do you see it unfold okay i do want
to point out a lot of people
well a lot of people thought it was a
fried chicken box which it it looks like
a fried chicken box right yeah and when
trump trumps in the frame before and
then you go to this you're like oh fried
chicken your brain goes to it it makes
sense but it is it is a beer box i want
to point that out yeah just just for
facts sake for kellyanne conway's sake
of facts yeah that is the alternative
facts right well you know she doesn't
want us to get the facts wrong so it is
a beer box not a chicken box well i and
i said this a long time ago if this
happens
we are
playing right into their hands green
energy
the windmills they don't work
they're too expensive they kill all the
birds they ruin your landscapes and yet
the environmentalists love the windmills
and i've been preaching this for years
the windmills and i had them way down
but the windows are the most expensive
energy you can have windmills cause
cancer okay okay cause cancer
dammit they cause any answer i can't
even listen to the rest of the clip it
listen
the guy asked him like is this gonna be
a long-term war what do we expect are
more people i mean basically what he's
saying is are more people gonna die are
we gonna have to continue this this this
idea that there's a war happening in a
foreign country that is just to
dismantle a democracy right that there's
an occupation that there are war crimes
happening and this guy's like the first
thought he had the very first thought
was i hate windmills
i eat windmills way more than i hate
putin
yeah it
it
you know
i can't even i don't even know it's just
like one of those things where i look at
it and i'm like how
did we ever elect this [ __ ] idiot and
the fact of the the fact of the matter
too is like here's a here's a softball
question right it doesn't take a lot of
insight and seems of like easy hey let's
let's look at what you know because you
have privileged information that no one
else has
from your time as president and then
also you're watching this play out and
you know you all he also still gets
daily briefings so he knows what's going
on
and instead of being like
you know without disclosing information
he says you know this is what the
situation looks like and this is like if
they make these certain moves without
obviously revealing stuff this is what i
anticipate could be a possible outcome
so he goes nah [ __ ] that windmills like
that's where we go like how do we ship
everything is but how he gets there is
it's so personal to him because there's
a story because he even says i've been
saying this for years the reason why
he's been saying it for years is because
in scotland there he has a [ __ ] golf
course that has his name on it he
doesn't own it right deutsche bank the
russians own it but there is a golf
course with his name on it and out off
the shore is windmills and he hates it
he hates it and he'll do anything to
anything he can say against his enemy it
doesn't matter the truth be damned he'll
say it against those and his first
[ __ ] thought was there's a murderous
dictator murdering innocent women and
children in a war where they're
occupying a democracy a sovereign nation
and his first thought is i hate those
[ __ ] windmills i mean honestly if you
think about it windmills are the real
dictators that is true you know maybe
maybe
just maybe there are the that
this the same people who own the space
lasers
maybe they own the windmills as well
i don't know i'm just saying i wouldn't
be surprised we should probably get uh
margie taylor green on the line it is
possible you know the other thing too a
good point he brings up is it kills the
birds maybe all birds are republican and
conservatives and trump supporters and
maybe that is the thing here is lib
libtards are making sure that windmills
exists to kill off all the conservative
republican birds i'm just saying yeah
maybe maybe i mean the windmills let the
democratic liberal birds go through and
then as soon as they try to fly through
the that windmill exactly you know it
times it so perfectly on a slow day as
well you know it sees it and it's like
oh [ __ ] we got to start moving we got to
start moving boom dead you know i think
that's probably that's probably right
they can definitely the windmills the
the the same people who own the space
later lasers they're sentient they are
sentient windmills i think no i think
that's what it is i think that i think
we're on to something
and trump trump is trump is like wake up
everyone wake up you know and see see
the light and see the windmills i mean
you gotta get woke and then it's like
wait which one is it right am i awake am
i asleep am i supposed to be awake am i
supposed to stay asleep i'm really um no
it is funny when people say that sorry
when people say sleepy joe and then
they're all he's he's woke or whatever
and it's like which isn't necessarily
woke but also if he was woke he'd be
awake he wouldn't be asleep right right
well i don't know guys come on it's it's
very it's very weird they they get it
turned around and speaking of of getting
turned around um we have the
dishonorable mention of this week which
is uh tulsi gabbard we were talking
about her earlier because she is she is
trending um she is trending in the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends this
morning uh because it appears
it appears that she may or may not be a
russian agent i don't know i mean the
the
uh the accusation has been thrown out by
the uh
by the dual russian american national so
so so d have you read more about this
story because i haven't read into the
story very deep uh yeah obviously we
know the news that uh
a russian uh national has been indicted
on federal charges for not for not um
disclosing themselves as a foreign agent
as they pushed right pro-putin policies
which there are there are registered
agents that are here in this country
that are registered as foreign agents
and they are
they are pushing pro-putin policies
inside the congress um that's where a
lot of this stuff comes from but
apparently this person was not
registered but still doing that same
thing which is kind of like uh mueller
she wrote let me let me uh bring that up
here yeah
um she called
she called it espionage light um here's
the yeah because she the reason that she
got it came up is because she was she
made i think two donations
uh she gave money uh to tulsi
right and that's what apparently she's
the only political candidate that they
she's given to so i don't know if
there's another organization and i'm not
really sure
um who the russian is uh because we've
seen we've seen russians be really
infiltrated
in uh republican politics we've seen and
i forget her name offhand uh we uh
jailed her and then actually
um
sent her back to russia after she
infiltrated the nra and several members
of the nra i don't know if you remember
that russian scandal um but uh let's see
the name of
let's see it here here's it's uh elena
branson also known as
elena nick
elena chernick
okay uh let's see if i can get back to
there the daily beast had the exclusive
um
elena branson
so that's the that's the tools he gave
which honestly and i i
i tweeted this this morning breaking
everyone in the country knew that tulsi
gabbard
was a russian asset duh like it wasn't
hard to figure out that tulsi gabbard
was
you know pro kremlin and pro putin right
it really was not hard to figure out you
just watch her interviews on fox news
and doesn't she also have a decent
following from white supremacy or white
nationalists well i mean of course she
does and and really she's not a democrat
and democrats shouldn't allow her to be
in the party i don't think they should
kick her the [ __ ] out you're not a
democrat you don't get to be a democrat
that's not democratic ideas you don't
have pro democracy ideas and i was
saying this earlier is that it it's
enough is enough of this [ __ ] where
people who are anti-democracy get to be
part of the big tent of the
quote-unquote democratic party because i
don't believe that most people who are
participating in politics right now who
who are voting for democrats are voting
blue as it were they're not actual
democrats right right they're just
pro-democracy yeah kelsey gabbard is not
that
she's not that
yeah she uh
she's not good
well if putin were to say it like he
said
she good she
she's very good she's very very very
she's very good
very very intelligent well and what
which also makes me think how long has
tulsi gabbard been
been being manipulated by pro-kremlin
police
who who's to say that there wasn't a
candidate in 2016 that was pro-kremlin
on the republican side and then in 2020
on the republican side but also maybe
maybe just maybe putin and the kremlin
had their hands into getting a
presidential candidate
on the democratic side to cause chaos no
totally i mean like it you know you
gotta hedge your bets right so you gotta
you know if i i wouldn't if i were
someone who was trying to spread
propaganda and you know
uh try to
throw down on democracy
i would place my bets in both corners
right because if i can cause
uh issue within one party
and plant another one in another party
you know i i'm only
betting i'm only like bettering my odds
on this situation right like i'm
doubling down
you know neither neither group knows
that i've got a you know
i've got a plant in each party
but the fact that it's there means that
you know if one party wins or one party
loses i still have a backup plan or at
least someone there and the other thing
too is like this is only based on
donations that we've seen two donations
i think it was that i said uh that was
made to to tulsi and
um
the other part two is you know something
that you just mentioned which is like
how long has it happened we don't know
like there might have been other
non-financial
gifts that were given or
trips or dinners
or this or that or like whatever like it
doesn't have to be these donations
it could be something in other forms and
also could be someone like it could have
been before
like
before she was uh uh
in congress right like there's
um
there's stuff that hap that could have
happened before that we don't know about
and then like she was shoved in that's
how she got into congress right maybe i
mean who knows yeah i mean i think i
think it'll all be investigated um and
we'll see how it goes so
congratulations to tulsi gabbard for um
for getting dishonorable mention it
wasn't that difficult for you in the
news that you were in at the last moment
there but we kind of struggled who was
alpha guck who is a dishonorable man and
i have my reason why this next person is
alphacock okay so let's let's show the
alvak and then and then you can explain
why you made this choice because i i
told you either way yeah um stephanie
grissom i think it's grissom right is it
grisham or is it grissom grisham grissom
grissom you know it's kind of like the
ingraham ingram you know thing i think
let's see but stephanie here grisham
it's grisham grisham not grissom okay
grisham
grisham
like john grisham like whatever like the
author stephanie stephanie here was a uh
press person for the first lady before
which i totally didn't even know that's
how
short and un uh
like uh irrelevant her
right her tenure as well the reason why
you didn't know and it was intentional
on steffi stephanie's part i believe so
that she could do things like the view
here the clip that we're going to show
why she ended up as alpha cuck
um because she's cocking she was cucking
for trump the whole time i think that's
is that why you made her the alpha
explain that part yeah so i there a
couple reasons i believe that uh a cuck
uh like herself in a situation is
because one she
yeah she was supportive of trump and all
the [ __ ] that he did
and this goes for also any author who
sat on information and did not release
it because they said i want to profit
off this even though it could make a
difference in the moment and reveal
something and
you know
change what's happening they said no no
i'm going to write about it that goes
for anyone uh on the right or the left
who did this
uh if you're privy to information and
you decided to withhold it and just like
[ __ ] cook it you know
uh you're a terrible person because
you're a coward
and you're weak and the fact that you
would sit by watch it happen and then
after the fact of you saying i'm gonna
write this book and i'm gonna i've got a
deal coming i got all this stuff if you
really cared about it you wouldn't try
to profit on it you wouldn't try to take
advantage of the situation and say oh
well a year plus after i was at office i
finally saw the light and you know what
i didn't just come forward and do a
bunch of interviews like say holy [ __ ]
guys this what he was doing was crazy it
was holy [ __ ] guys what he was doing is
crazy but hey that was just a preview of
the books if you want to learn more make
sure to buy the book it'll be available
on amazon and borders if that even i
don't even think that still exists uh in
any of your local like bookstores
walmart like make sure to buy it it's on
pre-sale like
that's that's the type of [ __ ] that i
see whenever somebody
releases a book and they talk about it
i'm like you sat there the publisher
knew obviously they're in a contract
they can't release information
but the person comes forward after
they've seen the light and then tries to
say that they you know oh i want
everyone to know it but i want everyone
to know with the price but don't you
think that the publishers are at fault
here too because what happened in the
trump administration i believe is these
publishers seen these big [ __ ] money
books
as
as the [ __ ] as the [ __ ] the trump
administration starts to tick away and
people start to leave they knew these
stories were here and the publisher
swooped in and said hey we'll pay you
money you just keep your mouth shut
until we're ready to release the story
basically what these publishers do is
they buy the story from these people and
make sure like john bolton bill barr and
stephanie grisham here they make sure
they make sure that those stories are
released when they want them for the
most potential for profit so it's not
just let's be [ __ ] honest here it's
not just the people writing the books
it's also these [ __ ] publishers who
are getting these people under contract
and selling them under the guise of
profit right i think that's part of it
yeah let's go to the clip of um
of uh stephanie here on the view and not
only is she talking about things that
are in the book um but
why she didn't tell the american people
this before i have no idea um i think
that he would have a completely
hands-off approach i think he'd be like
go on in there you know he he really
admired putin and i saw that firsthand i
saw him say to putin hey i'm going to be
tough on you in front of the cameras you
understand and once the cameras are gone
we'll have a real conversation he said
that he said that yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] that
was him going tough
on putin
well exactly
exactly um and so you know and he took
putin's word over our own national
intelligence so i think he would
absolutely just be like go for it and
then i actually think he would probably
talk about how tough he is and be in awe
of what he's doing as he's as he has
been the last
last couple of weeks it's just like i i
you know you want to put on a tree you
know you know who and putin
k-i-s-s-i-n-g
i i think i think we get the gist of the
clip because i think the view is gonna
it's gonna knock us i think the rest of
this like first comes collusion then
comes treason you know like
uh
but yeah they were definitely chaos ing
in the uh or
c-o-l-u-d-i-n-g in the tree you know
absolutely well i here's the other point
that i think you made is that
and we were talking about it earlier
before we got off on why she was the
alpha guck is
is that she no one knew she was the
press secretary yeah and and she didn't
when she goes in this uh on in this
interview or this little clip with the
view she talks about how you know she
was embarrassed and all this [ __ ] listen
the reason why she never got in front of
the camera is because she didn't want to
be held accountable for the video that
she would be on telling these lies like
kellyanne conway kelly yeah kaylee
mcaney
sarah huckabee sanders uh but also
the the most important part here is she
did lie she released official memos she
did lie for the administration she was
part of the perpetuation the [ __ ] she
sang was wrong yeah and her name is on
that documentary
she her
stamp of approval is all over that [ __ ]
well people may have not seen her on
camera very often obviously uh but at
the same time she's also the one that's
like yeah we should phrase it like this
we should communicate it this way
because she is the press secretary right
she's the one who's out there talking to
journalists and giving talking to the
press and making sure you know whatever
trump says that's so crazy doesn't sound
as crazy right like that's their job
they're trying to sugarcoat things and
she was well aware and she was complicit
and an accomplice and all of this
propaganda and misinformation that was
spread during this time that she was
there so
[ __ ] this whole like yeah [ __ ] her dude
the whole thing like you cannot you
cannot do that and then come back later
and say two years two [ __ ] years and
say i am reformed i have seen the light
i i know this is wrong yeah get them no
if you're gonna go when you're gonna
make a deal and then say oh you know
what you have an exclusive interview and
you have a i'm going to do a press tour
i'm going to profit off this i'm
profiting off of the deaths
of of american people i'm profiting off
of crimes that were done by the
president against the country i'm
profiting off all of the all of the also
all the things that we don't even know
right there's probably stuff that she
was privy to that was like uh don't say
that we should probably rephrase it like
this let me do a little wordsmith right
little magic on there that's exactly
what she did and she was totally aware
of what was happening so this whole like
i just woke up oh oh now you're woke now
you're awoke right
well you know that's why that's why
stephanie here got alpha cut because she
was cucking
for donald trump so congratulations
to stephanie for receiving alphacook of
the week now we want to go to the winner
here the winner is ron de santos death
santas death
santa's ronda santos that piece of [ __ ]
uh governor of florida the republican
government of florida um let's let's
give him his due and then you can tell
the audience why rhonda santos
was uh the bonehead of the week let's
let's give him his due here
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so so ronnie down in florida
yeah he decides to uh sign a bill but
tell the audience tell the audience give
us a breakdown
not of just the bill but some of the
lead-up and also some of the other
things that he did deserve because he's
been doing stuff to kill kids and
children in florida right he really is
attacking him so explain not just the
bill but also the little outburst that
he had
yeah so ron desantis uh you know uh the
devil reincarnate let's just call what
it is right this guy is is ron death
santas of florida he is dr death he is
uh i would say responsible for many of
the deaths that happened in florida
because of his uh you know male practice
or or rather his
lack of empathy or caring or just doing
just just what should be done right
during the pandemic he was like mass
don't work and da da i mean even last
week which feels like an eternity ago
even last week ron desantis [ __ ]
berated kids that were when he went to
go visit uh university of florida um
or usf went to go visit them and
immediately as he entered in was like
take over mass just take just take up
the mass like don't you don't the mass
don't work which is again misinformation
it's disinformation spreading that and
continuing to spread that is just
dangerous right uh especially for a guy
who uh you know his wife is now
cancer-free but
that type of uh
thinking and an ideology around the
pandemic and illness for someone who so
close to him is sick
is
is sick
um
but the reason that that ron there's
actually a couple things that happened
that uh that ron was the news for right
we've got the uh the stop woke act that
actually just passed the senate uh which
is the the florida ban on critical race
theory because uh you know white people
are afraid that anything that makes them
look like their ancestors or or they
themselves in the past have uh been
racist or have been
uh you know uh bad in any way it makes
them look bad no we can't talk about it
we can't mention it it's the stop woke
act and then of course there's the don't
say gay bill which is [ __ ] disgusting
and outrageous you know it's a
competition between florida and texas as
to who's going to be the worst human or
the worst governor in uh and that's
running right now but there are a couple
things that are happening you know and
and
as is happening you've got students who
you know from the lgbtq community and
others who are standing up you know who
are doing uh walkouts who are standing
up against ron desantis and the stump
[ __ ] and then today on top of that
there was desantis went after disney
because disney uh yeah he said you know
desantis blasted disney for being a woke
response on the florida sexual identity
in schools built the the uh don't say
gay and so now he's going after disney
because disney spoke up and said hey let
me maybe we should have a conversation
about this before we uh
we actually make this a real thing you
know even though he did you know sign it
so
um
it's just desantis is
bar none the worst person that i've seen
out there right now he is literally
throwing florida into the handmaid's
tale
straight fast right exactly so is this
is this the clip here that you're
talking about the disney thing yeah so
he goes after that's one yeah one of the
clubs that are spreading around i just
want to make sure i'm not i'm not
[ __ ]
insecure
oh yeah
is this is this a right winger i'm not
going to play this [ __ ] if it's that
right winger um i want to i'm gonna play
the clip of um
where he's saying about disney that's
clay travis i'm definitely not playing
that [ __ ] schlub
um [ __ ] clay travis um i wanna find the
video where he's talking about disney
though
um
if i can because because what does he
say specifically about disney
uh
he says uh
i'm reading an article right now where
he talks about uh because all these
right-wingers are loving this video that
right it says ron desantis is condemning
disney's response to florida's bill
banning discussion of sexual orientation
and identity in some classrooms calling
the company woke again it's they don't
know like
the idea that woke is a negative here
they're saying woke is hey you want to
acknowledge a person who doesn't
identify as what they were born into a
person who has a different lifestyle
like listen i don't
you know i'm not going to blame you for
choosing republicanism but it certainly
is a disorder of sorts i would say
uh right
but it said he's calling the company
awoken saying it's fallen for phony
hysteria from the corporate media phony
hysteria
they passed a don't say gay bill which
people like ben shapiro went after uh
mark hamill for and then mark hamill
went back after him and then ben shapiro
because ben shapiro was calling him in a
tweet he called him essentially uh
referred to him as a groomer saying he
was okay with this type of language and
well and that's about that's that's the
[ __ ] that's the [ __ ] that's that [ __ ]
pedophile [ __ ] this right cabal [ __ ]
that they're trying to right they're
trying to say that if you are then
you're just grooming which is insane
it's the same type of [ __ ] where it's
like oh somebody went transition just to
be able to get into a bathroom and
assault someone let's just break that
down right there like we've talked about
before and we've also shown how those
those uh those things were were lies
right um
it's just completely insane
that
you could make the assumption that hey
someone's gonna invest time money
emotional and physical stress on their
body and their mind to transition to a
different gender
be or sexual orientation because they
believe
uh that what they were originally you
know born into was not what they are
right they're like i'm a man or i'm a
woman or you know i you know they them
like it's
whatever they feel like and they say you
know what i don't feel comfortable in my
current position and i want to
transition
these people are saying oh you know what
the only people that do that are the
ones that want excuse to go into a
bathroom of the other like right it's
that that's not that's not it at all
right you and also the people that try
to do like oh well what about that uh
that uh
that female swimmer or that male swimmer
who transitioned to a female she's
breaking all these records and it's like
how many people
right now as
as athletes how many are actually out
there breaking records right how many
out there who have transitioned to do
this because again
you are changing your physical makeup
and like how your body is formed by
using hormones
to change yourself either one way or the
other to win a swimming race that's
right exactly to win a track meet like
do you think someone is going to invest
months years into uh uh hormone therapy
and transitioning so that they could
just beat you in a race or beat you in
some competition they would go that's
the point though is they would they
would they would do they would do sick
demented [ __ ] to me when race right but
they think so they think that so that
that's why they put this on the same
level and that's why that's why i've
always said it's so [ __ ] weird that
these people who talk about the bathroom
thing like you were saying
you are the only ones who are focused on
other [ __ ] people's genitalia in a
bathroom right no one else no no other
person is weird enough to [ __ ] try to
figure out what the next person in the
stall next to them what genitalia they
have it's only you [ __ ] weirdos that
are doing that right you brought up mark
hamill here i wanted to bring this up
with this beef between because i think
it is relevant um
because mark hamill is a is a very big
voice on twitter and so has been shapiro
for the other side uh to be frank about
it um and mark hamill the one thing i i
think we discovered about mark hamill
here is he has uh the dark twitter not
uh white you know he does the the i i do
i do i do the the dark version on my
phone
i do the light version on my computer to
be clear
so if these two screenshots that are
dark of mine it's from my cell phone if
you see white
and light screenshots it's from my phone
but ben shapiro here um obviously did a
quote tweet of mark hamill saying gay
gay gay gay gay gay gay gay gay gay
because um the
don't say gay bill everyone was saying
gay um i believe is it was the protest
which i think which is the dumbest
[ __ ] title i've ever heard of a bill
right right like i get what they're
trying to get at but at the same time
it's like don't say gay i'ma say gay
right right like like you're just
encouraging uh yeah at the obvious
protest but ben shapiro's stupid take
here is should i take it you wish to
indoctrinate small children into gender
and sexual ideology because that's the
only reason you're parroting um idiotic
propaganda again just the word gay
to ben shapiro is idiotic propaganda
once but also just the word gay just
triggered this response from ben shapiro
right he was offended by that right like
listen uh you're in your own home
you have your own rules whether they're
messed up or not right right
do not come after other people in their
own home right their home
their rules right my body my choice
right exactly exactly my my
i mean unless it happens
issues right right exactly that's what
i'm saying like whether they're right or
wrong like you know people do what they
want in their own home obviously uh
again
not all things that happen at home are
great or good but to infer
that there's just this blanket
thing that's happening right like
if you were if you were to ever discuss
uh
you know you're like hey listen i might
not be straight or like i might be like
this or whatever right like even having
that conversation they're like don't
[ __ ] do it right
don't even
don't even say the word gay if you do
i will [ __ ] come after you and it's
the blanket statement of like oh well if
we're talking about it that just means
that this person is a groomer or a
pedophile or some sort of other one
who's taken advantage uh sexually in the
home uh against a victim who's a child
like that is ridiculous the fact that
you're just gonna say blanket statement
it's all of you like you're all guilty
you know
uh and you and so when i see ben shapiro
just like knee-jerk reaction where he
just makes an accusatory statement
toward mark hamill which i'm pretty sure
ben shapiro deleted
his tweet that's what i saw some people
i don't i don't know but we'll we'll go
find that out here soon but uh mark
hamill responds back hi ben
hi ben hi ben i love mind reading acts
now guess which finger i'm holding up
love mark camel
this is perfect um that uh he would
respond like this and this is a
screenshot so it is there is a
possibility that this this tweet does
not exist we'll go back to the thread
here and see how it does i thought i saw
some people talk about how
people were like oh mark hamill is a
true jedi he made this and got him to
delete the tweet right like delete your
tweet to get your tweet is that what is
that this is not the tweet you want to
send right there
you must delete this tweet i i'm just
seeing screenshots of it here let's see
if we can uh
um
you think it would be you think someone
would have recorded scroll all the way
to the top i saw people talk about it
all the way to the top
scroll down
yeah see it's all screen shots wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
screenshot
scroll down screenshot screenshots
[Music]
wait keep going go oh wait wait wait
wait wait keep going keep going a little
bit more right there boom go up up up up
up up up
right here
yeah up a little bit
right there right just made benchburg's
latest tweet in point five seconds the
man really is a jedi master okay well
the
tg's what he said is i don't know i i
haven't confirmed but that's what i saw
people talking about well let's let's
let's do something here let's go
to old uh
benny's page one lumber boy as i call
him do you remember the lumber thing
where yeah and you bought a board poplar
wood yeah
i'm the fine owner of some poplar wood i
i bought a piece of two-foot poplar and
put it in a plastic bag
like what the [ __ ] go support home depot
what was that even about was it some
kind of
uh woke thing or some [ __ ] i'm not
saying this tweet i think he did delete
it
let's see what it what what does the
tweet say
and the indoctrination of children are
you gonna you're gonna just try to
search it here yeah
uh indoctrination would prob well he
probably writes that in almost every
tweet so you may have a list of them
there that would pop up
uh of course this [ __ ] idiot is
retweeting andy no
and
yeah
that's all you need to know about ben
shapiro that he's a [ __ ] nazi and
he's a fascist is he's retweeting andy
no it's not very
difficult and complicated would appear
that it says the tweet says
indoctrination
of indoctrinate indoctrinate children
doctor indoctrinate children okay hold
on yep well let's go back let's let's uh
it says
here's the screenshot from hamill
indoctrinate small children okay all
right let's look for that indoctrinate
small children doctrinate small children
but yeah the lumber fiasco where he was
no no he didn't delete it it's still
there it's still there okay it's still
there
uh pull that up because i wanna i wanna
tell him how much i hate this tweet it's
it's going to boost his tweet but i
still want to tell him how much it
[ __ ] sucks
i want to tell this all right there you
go this is it
copy
and paste
here is the tweet so it it is not
deleted yeah it is not deleted it's
still there
uh because you know here's mark hamill's
original tweet
because he was quote tweeting occupy
democrats florida students spoke loud
and clear this week against the gop's
bill
to cancel free speech and lgbtq people
because that's what they're actually
trying to do the party of cancer culture
is trying to cancel a whole group of
people
just because of one word and mark hamill
uh
and of course here has been shapiro's
tweet [ __ ] this guy
your tweet [ __ ] sucks and you know it
your tweet sucks
it sucks big time yep
okay um so
let's uh
so
basically in terms
of the don't say gay bill and also some
other things where um
rhonda sanders woke at
the [ __ ] masks the way he dealt with
the pandemic
well i i mean
the fact that the fact that he not only
attacks children in legislation but
verbally attacks children at his own
press conference as they're going to be
his props
um
and he continues his little uh his
little covet theater it really is it
really is there is nothing that does not
trigger ron desantis
healthcare
or it's uh your you know how you are as
a person you know how you identify your
gender your sexuality how we how we
discuss history right you know like
anything that makes him feel
uncomfortable mm-hmm across the board
right ron desantis will put his stuff
into it that's right
he wants to just say hey you know what i
don't like the history that makes us
look bad us white people uh right you
know direct family whatever uh i don't
wanna i don't want you to wear a mask
because it shows that my policies aren't
actually right working
uh i don't want you to uh
talk about being gay because that makes
sense uncomfortable
and the guy is it's what happens when
you've got someone in in a leadership
position and i say the leadership
position that is weak and insecure and
uncomfortable and and so pathetic and
petty this is what you get this person
like ron desantis and many others on the
gop and the gqp will do as much as they
can to suppress and silence and make
sure that no one else can speak out and
no one else has a fair voice unless they
agree within the echo chamber that they
live in
that is that that's a good synopsis so
let's give let's give ron desantis
that homophobic piece of [ __ ] let's give
him his due he won
just
just he'd
[Applause]
is he that much better or just that much
worse than trump i think i think he's
working well i think he's worse and then
the reason why i think he's worse is
because he has much more of a future in
the republican party than trump does and
he also i would say
was it is able to pass more in
legislation than trump was ever able oh
well that happened trump's a buffoon
trump couldn't write anything trump's a
buffoon uh desantis is way smarter than
trump that's the scary part about death
santa so let's give o ronnie boy his due
here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
maybe there should be a recount maybe
trump is going to call it a big lie and
i mean he might get the cyber ninjas on
the case i don't know we we could i i
would definitely hand over our data to
the cyber ninjas wouldn't you
uh if you want to vote for bonehead of
the week go at tony michael's pod we
have the bonus that we pull every single
week it's good to exercise the voting
skill
so go vote on twitter for bone end of
the week and uh stick around uh right
after the song here we'll have some more
announcements stick around
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm getting really good at this
transition yeah it was almost it was
seamless hot on yeah
hot on yeah commercial in there i know
uh great bonehead of the week a very
very close close race there i that is
the closest we've ever had on boat night
of the week by the way yes yeah that is
uh never the world nail biter you know
we had over 2 000 people voting which is
i think the highest that we've had yeah
they're like 20 20 big thanks to
yes for for pushing that stuff out there
that's right so we'll keep we'll keep
doing the bone in the weak bowl and
we'll try to get midas to uh to send it
out to everyone to the minus money so
they get the vote that way you guys can
watch all every friday in the second
hour we go through bone of the week go
through the poll go through your votes
and you guys get to choose who the bone
hand of the week is so don't forget to
go follow at tony michaels pod follow me
at the tony michaels follow gay i am
gabe sanchez over on twitter to keep up
with all the polls and all the news by
the way we have uh i want to make an
announcement we're going to be airing
the extended version of walters
interview which was a great interview
yesterday it's hilarious and there's
like 45 more minutes of laughter yeah
you guys got to see it it's just
straight laughter no talking just
laughing just ha ha
mostly me laughing because i can't hold
myself together because walter's so
[ __ ] funny but go go check out
again follow us on twitter we'll be
announcing where we're gonna be playing
that this weekend we'll play the
extended version it's almost like two
hours long right i mean the whole thing
uh yeah a little less than two hours i
think pretty close so there's like an
extra 45-50 minutes of what we've seen
yesterday so go check that out um also
what you can do while you're watching
that extended episode to see how many
times george soros yeah pops
he makes a cameo how many times
because it seems like it seems like that
soros was muting walters mike when he
was talking about getting paid by george
soros exactly any time he talked about
you know george like georgie said
yeah don't don't say nothing don't say
he's got his minecraft
it was great it was right right right
and we have you have some other things
that you're trying to work on with
bonehead kind of a march madness thing
or something so yeah for legal reasons i
can't call march madness right i'm
pretty sure they'll come after us oh
okay well we won't call it we we won't
die
right but i definitely will yeah yeah
yes we will not call it march madness
the idea is it'll be bonehead madness
now i don't know if i'll jump into the
second round when it's just 32 teams
that are playing because the one
previous is you know whatever 64 or
right or no or even more than that but
uh it's a lot of boneheads i don't know
if i can come up with i mean i'm sure if
i really tried i can come with anybody
but how many poles would people want to
take during the day right right right
well we'll see how this works out we'll
try to put it together for you guys so
phone head madness we're not we're not
calling it march mad yeah not march
madness because this is not march
madness this is bonehead madness right
it's two completely different things
yeah it is you know it's like we got the
hateful eight and the deplorable four
you know right exactly yeah exactly uh
so bonehead madness look forward to that
also check out the interview um and
we're interviewing someone this
afternoon we're recording it's going to
be big next week
we're going to ask him about crypto
we're going to ask him about nfts uh to
get his take he is um somewhat of an
expert on these things so i'm really
excited about the interview we had this
afternoon to record so stay tuned for
that amount an announcement next week as
as we get that uh interview recorded and
and edited um i i think that that'll be
that'll be a really good that'll really
be a good good interview for next oh
yeah i'm looking forward i'm sure it'll
be another juicy interview right i mean
he's a charismatic guy so go subscribe
to the youtube channel so that you do
not miss those interviews do not miss
the extended walter version do not miss
the interview for next week and remember
we're here every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central youtube twitter
twitch every one of them every single
weekday thanks for joining us all the
channels all of them all of those and
all the all the the boycotted uh
directories as well spotify apple google
iheartradio you can go to
thetonymichaels.com you can find our
merch stores you can also find all the
podcast links and all the social links
so follow us there go there do your
thing
like subscribe all that kind of good
stuff
and until until monday
until monday surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking